[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non je crois que vous savez on est dans
la dent dans le registre en fait de la
communication politique c'est à dire
qu'il faut toujours avoir des réflexions
et des déclarations plus percutantes les
unes que les autres
je crois que la période et le contexte
dans lequel s'inscrivent ces propos
parle de lui-même c'est à dire qu on est
à l'aube d'échéances électorales et que
naturellement j'ai que au delà de du
titre la consistance et le discours du
ministre du président de la république
sont vides de sens en fait aucune mesure
nouvelle n'est annoncée
rien ne permet d'annoncer un changement
de situation significatif alors tout
dépend c'est pas simplement un problème
de financement c'est un problème d'
influence plus globalement qui
s'explique par le fait que la france est
une démocratie et que naturellement
certains états étrangers convoite le
vote musulman dans le but justement
d'infléchir ou de contraindre
la diplomatie française et les autorités
françaises locales au ministériel à
prendre un certain nombre de décisions
qui pourraient leur être favorable sur
la scène internationale donc on a par
tradition les pays du maghreb le maroc
et l'algérie notamment puisque la
tunisie
en tout cas sous l'ère bourguiba ben ali
était un pays laïc donc qui se
désintéressait des questions religieuses
mais également la turquie de plus en
plus nous avons également des
financements issus de la ligue islamique
mondiale donc l'arabie saoudite le
pakistan le bangladesh parfois également
le qatar pour ce qui est de la mouvance
des frères musulmans mais
l'investissement financier reste modérée
c'est parfois je dirais le financement
de communication de chaînes de
télévision deux médias alternatifs est
également l'emploi d'agents d'influencé
si je puis dire qu'ils agissent sous
couvert de dignitaires religieux
en france la composante turc en fait de
l'islam de france dont qui est le
conseil consultatif des musulmans turcs
de france qui est basée à bagnolet et
est un organisme du cfcm rattaché au
cfcm dont le président a déjà exercé la
fonction de président du conseil
français du culte musulman et c'est un
organisme pyramidale dont les membres du
bureau sont désignés directement par
l'ambassadeur de turquie en france
est-ce que l' influence des turcs en
france est grandissante je n'en sais
rien en europe peut-être puisque la
population turque est beaucoup plus
influentes en allemagne ceci dit
effectivement ce qui peut parfois
inquiété les autorités françaises à
juste titre ou pas je n'en sais rien
c'est la nature même du régime turc
puisque le résultat est
principalement affiliés à la cape est
donc un parti réputé proche de
l'idéologie des frères musulmans
l'uejf n'existe plus sur ce nom le nom a
changé je pense que de mémoire
l'association s'appelle aujourd'hui
musulmans de france
un terme qui porte à confusion parce
qu'on peut très bien être musulman de
france sans adhérer à la vision de cette
association ni même y adhérer au plan
juridique
ceci dit effectivement cet organisme a
démontré par le passé et dans le présent
une volonté d'ingérence dans les
affaires politiques françaises la
volonté d'instituer un islam politique
est effectivement une proximité avec les
frères musulmans à l'international
notamment en egypte puisque cette
association a régulièrement invité tariq
ramadan qui le petit fils du frère du
fondateur du mouvement des frères
musulmans dont qu'arsenal badenas mais
également les frères musulmans des pays
tels que le qatar
parfois les frères musulmans
palestiniens et et frères musulmans
issus de bien d'autres pays
absolument la majorité des dignitaires
musulmans de france sont des agents
rémunérés par l'étranger pour accomplir
des missions d' influence de l'opinion
publique française et de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la rue musulmanes en
france et donc parfois agités de façon
excessive le spectre de l'islamophobie
se porter comme partisan excessif de la
cause palestinienne et sur bien d'autres
sujets est naturellement bon alors
l'anecdote c'est que
je dirais que les agents sont souvent
des agents doubles en fait parfois ils
peuvent effectivement renseigner les
services français et agir pour le compte
d'un état étranger et l'anecdote la plus
criant c'est celle de cet agent de
sécurité qui a été interpellé à orly
parce qu'il avait réussi à extirper des
informations d'un capitaine de police
affilié justement à la paf d'orly pour
identifier les fichiers s qui
transitaient par les postes frontière et
transmettre au royaume marocain
l'ensemble des identités des fichiers
res qui transitait par l'aéroport
mais au plan religieux le le bon l'un
des fondateurs d'une bombe ce couvert du
secret défense je ne peux pas donner
plus de précisions mais le l'un des
fondateurs d'une grande organisation
musulmane française était au moment de
la fondation de cette fédération un
agent de la dst de l'ancienne direction
de la surveillance du territoire